okay Magnus up six four
needs to draw to to win this one but
he lost three in a row and what a match
it's been especially the middle stretch
by kiril chef shenko
not over yet
I don't think Magnus knows anything
about the structure can't recall him
having played it
with either color ever
no
A4 is all the rage you don't want to
grab space with A5 or you want to
provoke black to play five
so which this Square gets weakened this
Pawn could be a Target
um
how much do you think Magnus
know about the format of the tournament
do you think you realize when he's won I
really have not paid too much attention
no I think he knows this is the
quarterfinals so normally normally he
knows stuff like that
but really knows that he needs six and a
half yeah
sometimes Knight E5 Works in such
positions
takes takes default you regain a piece
that didn't happen
it's an actual code F4
huh
Carol
attentive
takes Bishop takes
it's easier to play for why the queen
can come here this square is a little
weak
not the construction you won't put black
out of this line is not time to go
Knight T4 officially six because 94 he
gets kicked with C3
just a bad position he goes B5 but after
a b
c b as a little jump
this oh he missed it
he missed the jump
went out if I have a different jump
and less good and C4 Blitz up by kiril
1096 Queen C5 check
showing that he hasn't lost his motor
he's back in business
yeah Carol one is three games so he was
satisfied he got the prediction
yeah it's fair
he also didn't want to upset
the prestigious hosts
cdcd
Queen B4 but he's still
foreign
five
horizontal attack
okay pushed covered
yeah
still a game
on
Magnus no Kira also has played amazingly
fast he's just very very strong place
but
19 years old
20.
over 20.
cousin taking some time
what are you rooting for in those match
like predictions of years coming true
I'm not
to take into account
I'm not really rooting for anyone to be
honest like I'm still talking I don't
know if it's best for me if Magnus wins
the tournament or if he doesn't win the
tournament I guess him losing in the
final would be the best outcome
if he loses so yeah we have to we have
to root for Magnus in this one you
probably need them to make the finals
for Max attention and then the upset
here
[Music]
the upset he loses to
times probably rough
things to do office to get the most
press like then
yeah but Dubose beaten before if we
could like we could do it as a grudge
match
and in final game Ralph plays one G5 and
beats him that's also not bad
we just we need a story or it's five and
a half five and a half of Magnus goes
one three four and Ralph results
[Laughter]
it could be good too
yeah I I feel like if Magnus wins the
tournament he probably won't defend his
title next year
he doesn't win he probably won't change
change the title next year either I
don't think there's that much of stick
food
I think there's a chance there's there's
hope at least
maybe not much but somehow so yeah so
you're telling me there's a chance
I think there's a chance
what's going on here Bishop H6 takes
takes
the tactic let's say six
at six is a sick movement
takes nice soundtrack King F7 95
and Y is better because this special is
also hanging and if Queen C6
then there's rookie six
attacking the queen well that Beast is
saying
and it didn't happen Magnus went when he
won
and F4 rookie five
who's better and why
Magnus is bad because he's Magnus look
something happened to the cameras
fit to screen
Magnus is better because it's Magnus but
the position
it's just messy oh the other match is
over
we did follow it in we did great great
detail and we're being joined by
same Savion congratulations Sam well
pleasure thank you
tough match yeah very tough match today
he's a very fast player
so six and a half four and a half that's
yeah
at the end
nice
before we get to the highlights I'm not
sure if you can see the screen we're
just watching the last moments of the
Carlson versus chefchenko match where
Kimberly fought very hard but now he's
down six four in defeat lose this one
the match is over I did win three in a
row in the middle so it was a tough
match but
almost like he's not winning
so this will be your opponent in the
next round who would you prefer to play
I'd never played Magnuson like any Blitz
game so definitely oh wow yeah
awesome yeah that'll be great to watch
where's the next round tomorrow
yeah both semi-finals tomorrow
Sam how did you get lured into this
tournament because some of a lot of
strong players showed up but it's very
unclear like who got in how and why and
how how did it happen with him
I mean um I mean dodgy just wrote to me
I I really had nothing else to do so I
decided to accept it that seems to be
the main story yeah that was also my Mr
story yeah although he had nothing else
to do and he said no initially but
eventually go
so what can future organizers learn from
this just asking people might help you
yeah probably
where are you based are you are you from
from New York or from the state of New
York because I thought you were on the
west coast but uh I lived in the west
coast like 10 years ago then we moved to
Boston area Massachusetts all right
right okay because I Googled it the
other day I thought you were a West
Coast guy but it said you were from
corner yeah we've I've moved around
quite a bit I've been here for the last
nine years now
see Magnus has won his match as well 7-4
congratulations to him